peter schrager insider for the nfl
network
a former male cheerleader and uh one of
the stars for good morning football
peter good to have you on how are you
great to have you on no cheerleading in
my history but big fan
of the uh the danettes getting out there
for taco falls
oh it was great uh let me ask you our
poll question mclovin hit traeger with
the poll question today
okay which team would you bet a week's
pay will not be in the super bowl
uh are going to win the super bowl over
the next decade the jets
the lions the bengals the washington
football team the jaguars
and dan asked us to put the giants on
there so
won't win yeah won't win a super bowl
yeah looking at the roster right now and
looking at what's coming up i
i'm gonna say it's tough for me to say
anything other than the jets at the
moment right now that was
last night was brutal guys i mean i feel
like i'm piling on i'm
we're you know i'm in new york it's just
the lack of talent
on that roster right now and frank gore
being your go-to guy at age 37 is a cool
feature
and a nice fun you know human interest
story that tom rinaldi would do
uh before but it shouldn't really be the
reality of what's going on
and i was pointing out how bad this is
you know that you have
a rookie quarterback making his first
start short work week
on the road and the jets allow
37 points i i but i don't know what was
worse
the offense or the defense with the jets
at least with greg williams i'm supposed
to have a
defensive genius there you know there
were cheap shots there
they've had six roughing the passer
calls on their team so far i mean this
is
this is on greg williams a lot too not
just adam gase
there's a there's a false bravado that
comes with it you know jamal adams gets
shipped out and it's you know i think
jamal might get bored
in that scheme and like there's a laugh
and a wink to the camera and it's like
i don't know man i i watched the jets
last night and you said the four
roughing the passers they lead the
league by a ton in that penalty
they give up 37 points they're
undisciplined there's penalties all over
and after the game like vic fangio is
like a beloved guy in the league and i
don't know him and gases relationship
but fangio's not even shaking gases hand
because of the way things ended it's
just
it's one thing to lose i said this on on
good morning football the other day it's
like
if you got burro and t higgins and
you've got this young up and coming team
and they're coming to together like
you'll watch your team
i'm watching jeff smith and no offense
to jeff smith
at boston college undrafted great story
and i'm watching brexton berrios and i'm
like
they've got first round picks in the top
10 every year where are like where is
the talent why is this so bleak for jets
and jets fans
last night was brutal but if you're the
jets
and the giants and you have let's say
somehow one of those two gets it the
number one pick overall
what are they doing you got sam darnold
you got daniel jones is there any
question
what you're doing with that number one
overall pick
the jets one is a discussion to have has
sam darnold regress this year is the
question and you can say oh it's gases
fall i
i look over at some of these other teams
and a lot of teams have injuries and a
lot of teams have
problems and their quarterbacks are not
taking giant steps back i
if you love darnold and you really think
that donald's your future you could
probably trade a first overall pick for
two
or three other first-round picks and
then you've got the jamal adams pick and
you've suddenly got a
a a treasure chest or treasure trove of
draft picks
but i don't know like do you just say
let's scrap it and start again and if
sam darnold goes on and has a great
career at the steelers or the falcons or
whoever else god bless them it just
wasn't meant to be
trevor lawrence is sitting there number
one i don't care what the team is if you
finish so bad that you couldn't get out
of the number one spot you have to
consider it long and hard
yeah because if you are if you have
trust in your quarterback
then you don't finish with the worst
record in football exactly right
and cliff kingsbury came in to arizona
and said hey
josh rosen some nice parting gifts for
you you get to keep your jersey
i'm i'm going to bring in kyler murray
here i think that would be the situation
even
with the giants with daniel jones
potentially let's see how
daniel jones finishes but he looks
sloppy he looks like he he's no sure
thing right now
and you know the giants fans i hear from
them a lot and the giants fans are like
yeah but saquon got hurt and
okay well dave gettleman's had three
picks in the top six
over the last three years and they've
all been offensive selections and the
giants have one of the worst offenses in
the league like at some point
the fans are right to look for a pound
of flesh and say no wait a second maybe
we should have taken a running back
second overall
or maybe we didn't have to take general
jones sixth overall or maybe we didn't
take an offensive tackle fourth overall
the draft is such an imprecise science
and yet i look at the 49ers
i look at the ravens all these teams
have injuries and yet they don't seem to
miss that many beats
the giants and jets have injuries these
teams get blown out by 20 points
to teams like bret ripon lead teams and
nick mullen flood teams it's
i feel bad because dan you know the new
york market is so
important for the nfl so important for
the nfl and
already by october 5th neither team is
relevant in the conversation
i just saw this tweet from bomani jones
of the mothership
he said did kovid save adam gase's job
if you had that stadium full of fans
last night
how ugly would have would it have gotten
uh i i don't know that that might be a
stretch
but you know sometimes we do react to
how your fans react
yeah and look the jets fans are vocal so
whether they're in the building or not i
don't know if bomani uh reads the new
york papers and listens to the new york
radio like it is being
trust me it's resonating how upset
people are with adam gase this is not an
excuse for gays
and it's not a great reason but who are
you going to
is greg williams going to be your head
coach moving forward is dao loggins
is jim bob cooter like it's almost
if you fire gase all right you get your
pound of flesh for a day and there's
still
four months left in the season and now
you've got greg williams or jim bob
cooter as the head coach
and then what like at the very least
gase and darnold seem to have some sort
of relationship the bye week's in
november
i i'm not surprised i didn't fire him
after last night but i also
i don't think there's an alternative on
that staff and that's nothing great to
rally around it's not that i'm saying
give gase a shot i'm just saying
i don't know if there's a better option
in-house adam schefter tweeted don't
know if you saw this two more titans
players tested positive this morning in
tennessee
for a source there i know that this game
has been postponed
i'm concerned about the following week
and the number of positives
and you're going to be hosting a game
against the buffalo bills
you know quarantining and i don't know
that like this is
this could get a whole lot bigger what
do you think
these results come out about 9 30 a.m
every day so
i really am doing uh you know all i can
in the morning to not stare at that
clock and say what's gonna happen when
we get the results from these player
tests
the one that i'm watching and i'm still
watching are the vikings because
if the titans can keep it within the
titans and that is a terrible story and
it's
it's horrible for the nfl and it's of
course bad for the people who have
coveted 19 in the tennessee organization
but if they can keep it within that we
can kind of manage and work with bye
weeks and work with their opponents
the second it starts spreading like an
amoeba and you say okay well the vikings
played the titans and now we know the
vikings have two guys so that the
vikings opponent this week the texans
they can't have a game and then next
week
that's when this thing really sets the
season off the rails
i think everyone is trying their best
but when you see aj tyrell from the
falcons
has it and you know i know for a fact
the falcons
coach gm those guys weren't sleeping
saturday night because they didn't know
what they were getting
sunday morning when the results came out
it was a blessing that none of them had
it
but that's every team right now and the
season and the schedule
it is as fluid as it could be i i i am
sorry for all the tennessee fans i'm
sorry for the pittsburgh fans but if we
can keep it to two teams and find a way
to get this thing back on the tracks
that is a major win for the nfl right
now i've got an upset of the weekend
or at least a strong potential for
upset of the weekend you want to guess
you're taking the lions over the saints
no
i'm taking the dolphins over the
seahawks
do tell do you want in on that i i'm
very
intrigued by that let me hear your
reasoning i don't have any reasoning
it's just last week i said the lions
would beat arizona
for no other reason then they shouldn't
beat arizona
yeah i've got the dolphins beating
russell wilson jr the third
i love it um i love the courage i love
the take and it's not crazy
it's one of those where everyone's
pumping up seattle yet their defense has
shown a lot of weaknesses and fitzy's
got 10 days
looked good on thursday night wait who
knows i didn't go that far to say you
can't give ryan fitzpatrick 10 days to
prepare for you
you're in trouble if we know one thing
in sports if we've learned anything in
our combined
you know 60 years of doing this i would
think we know that you don't give ryan
fitzpatrick no you do not
he is he is the greatest september
player probably in history
except for patrick mahomes who hasn't
lost
and hasn't thrown an interception 32
touchdowns zero interceptions in the
month
of december uh september the great thing
that i found out and this is my breaking
news when he was doing that one
two three four that you saw in the video
and he was counting him out that wasn't
his touchdown passes that was
that was in response and i hear this
from multiple people in kansas city
to him being voted forth in the nfl
network like who even cares about the
nfl
that's how deep he's looking for
motivation because everyone has just
told him he's the greatest thing ever
he's like
the nfl network voted me forth on their
uh top 100 list i'm gonna
do something i mean that is next level
looking for that's michael jordan
looking for motivation
at le bradford smith type stuff yeah but
i i also wonder
and i i said in 10 years from now like
what is what it what would be
a disappointing season for patrick or a
career for patrick mahomes
because you know now we're looking at a
dynasty they've acknowledged that they
think they could be the patriots and
have a dynasty here
if he has two super bowl wins after 15
years
is it a successful career
yeah but if you were to say if you're
patrick mahomes would you sign up
for two right now knowing you can't get
three four five and six how would you
feel i would think it would be
it would be not fulfilling expectations
yeah to your point but i wonder that
you know with it's a half billion dollar
contract that's just this
contract and then the next contract he's
going to get but
you know i i just wonder how we're going
to spin this because
we tend to look at like lebron hey you
won three titles going to win a fourth
yeah he also lost six of them like we
always yeah but
yeah but brady look at the number of
super bowls he's lost
uh montana never you know we always want
to skew to the negative here
yeah the crazy part about what mahomes
is doing is that he's doing it in this
era of football with
parody being like the number one most
important thing from the league whether
it be scheduling or whether it be free
agency or just how they do it and
they've gotten better
they brought back everybody and i try
making this point as many times as
possible like the coaching staff is all
back too
so when the eagles beat the the patriots
you see frank wright get a head coaching
job and john d filippo takes an
offensive coach
coordinator and like the coaching staff
is decimated over an eagles
upset win over the patriots chiefs run
the table in the playoffs
win everything and none of their coaches
get hired for any other jobs
i guess the only potential of this thing
falling apart is like the enemy gets a
job then spags gets a job and then mike
kafka who's a quarterback's coach
gets a job that's when this thing called
but the players they're all young really
good and like each other like i don't
know if they're getting any worse
anytime soon
great to talk to you and enjoy your
weekend always great to see you thank
you bud
you me and fitzy let's go yeah great in
september peter schrager the star of
good morning football
or so he tells us